- Hi, it's Benito Skinner,
a.k.a. Benny Drama.
And today I'm christening the digital hub
at the Drew Barrymore show.
I've got something in store for Drew
that I think she's gonna love,
because what's better than one Drew?
Two Drews, let's do this.
(upbeat music)
Double, double, toil and trouble, ah!
So good.
Yes!
Let's do this.
- Oh my God, it's like multiplicity.
- I know, look.
- Ah.
- Look at this.
(Drew exclaiming)
- Okay, wait, sit down.
- Yes, oh my God, of course.
- So, as much as I love the
idea of there being two of us.
- Two of us.
- Twins.
- I have to say that I would love
if I could ask Benny a question.
- Oh my God.
Okay, I think he's in here somewhere.
Yes, yes.
- Knock, knock.
- Knock, knock, I'm just
like, uh-uh, sorry, method.
(Drew laughing)
Not today, Drew.
Wow, okay, yes, I'd be honored.
- Benny, would you come out to play?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, hi Drew, I'm here.
- I wanna ask you some
questions because I think
that you have really,
truly changed the game
and you might have some real
pearls of wisdom for people
who wanna find their voice in this world.
What is your process?
How do you come up out of thin air
in the ether with your characters?
- So, sometimes it'll be
like, I'll get a line stuck
in my head or something
that I think is funny.
Like when I did Jonathan
Van Ness as Jesus,
I kept hearing them say
like, "Okay, Judas, rude."
And it just like kept going,
so something like that
where I'm like, almost like
build a video around that.
And then sometimes it's just
kind of like a life experience.
Like I got my haircut
one time from this girl
who just like made me feel so safe,
but was definitely telling
me too much about her life.
And it just after a few
haircuts that were like,
that was like, this character
of Jenny came to be.
And then I was like, she
would also work at Mac.
Like this girl is like she's
hair and makeup, she does both.
She's like, she's got multiple jobs.
- When you write stuff in your notes app,
do you like go back and revisit it
or does it like kind of fall in the dump?
- Well, sometimes I think a
really good idea will come
up multiple times and then
also a really good idea
you won't see, so like if I see
someone do something similar
or if I feel like the video
I'm doing, isn't a fresh take
or something like that, I'm like,
"Okay, I don't think I need
to spend hours editing that."
You know, I wanna do something I'm excited
about, that feels fresh and new.
I think a good example is
like I saw a fellow comedian
of mine, Meg Stalter, she
did like a Barbie video.
And I'd always had this
idea of maybe doing Barbie
and then like Ken and, so
instead I was just like, wait,
let's make it together.
you're Barbie and I'll be Ken.
And then sometimes it'll
just be like, it's time.
Some things I can do fast, which is nice.
Like, you know, the Courtney Kardashian,
Travis Barker relationship,
I saw that kind of spring up
and I was like, oh,
well I have to act now.
- How do you think, like,
cause comedy can be funny
at other people's expenses
and somehow you go
all the way with it and it's charming.
And like, I feel like
the Kardashians love you.
- They've been very
sweet, I mean, I always,
for me to do what I do and do
an impression or something,
it just, I have to be invested
in the person and love them.
So, I've never done a video on something
that I didn't care about.
Like everything I've done
I think it's really more
of an omage cause I'm
like, I love it and I think
this thing is funny about
it and I really want people
to feel like they're
in on the joke with me.
I think people, you know,
who I've made videos
of, they feel the love.
Cause it is there, I really, I don't,
I never want to be an internet bully
or so like, that was never my goal.
- It is so loving what you do.
- Yeah, I hope.
- It is, but it doesn't
compromise on the funny.
How'd you prep as they say to be.
- To be you?
- Aha.
- I, oh my God, okay, I
think just, it goes back
to me only doing like impressions
of like something I consume a lot of.
So, I mean, I've seen
everything you've made
and I think I, you
know, I watch your show,
like, I follow you on
Instagram, so it's like,
I've studied you so much,
but it just, I like,
I don't know, I think since I was a kid,
I just like love picking up on,
you know, the nuances
of, of what someone does.
- So I think you're walking a tight rope.
That's very difficult for
people to create and stay on
and you're doing like
the best job with that.
- Thank you.
- It's true.
- We are also similar,
we've seen, you know,
so many of the same things
and I feel like, you know,
I'm fortunate I have a
collaborator who's, you know,
also my boyfriend and my partner.
So it's like, if he also feels it, that's,
I almost like test to
sometimes where I'm like, wait,
can you watch this really quick?
And no matter what, he'll also
be like, "Ooh, not that one."
- Yeah, in fact, I'll end the
conversation with this note.
And I think it's so true
for this conversation
as my friend Elisa
texted me the other day.
And she's like, "What do you think?
Like, should I do this or say this?"
And I said, "I think if
you're questioning it,
you have your answer."
- Yeah, it's not worth it.
- Trust that weird little sensation
that has doubt and uncertainty.
- Yeah.
- Like, don't risk it.
- That said, you take so many risks
and yet just, you just don't step in it
and it's such a beautiful thing to see.
I think everybody's
ideal dream relationship
or a lot of people's ideal
dream relationship is
to be believed in, to be supported
and to actually have someone
like collaborate with you.
How sexy and fun.
- Yeah, I'm literally crying.
Sorry.
- Barbara Walters goes digital.
- I just have this, I'm like, oh my God,
I'm literally sitting with drew Barrymore.
I mean, it's just, I feel
so lucky to do what I do.
- You are pioneering something
and this will get traced back to you.
And it's just so wonderful
cause it is hard to come up
with something new in this
world and you're doing it.
- And so are you.
We're so lucky to have you.
- Oh, thank you.